CBS News political contributor Bob
Schieffer is here this is the 25th
election he is covered in his long
stellar career Bob do you like us saying
that this is a 25th election you covered
you like that yeah okay good
it means I'm still here I hope you're
saying it's this 26 76% of the voters
think Americans are becoming more
divided you see all the politicians
talking about unity there so how do you
see this election shaping up what does
it remind you of anything not anything
really but I think what we saw last
night is the country is more deeply
divided I think then probably it was
after the election in 2016 and I don't
know where this goes I mean I said
before this before this election I
minute sincerely and honestly I didn't
know how it was going to come out I felt
I'd never felt that clueless about what
was going to happen but you know the
conventional wisdom was that the
Democrats were probably going to take
the House Republicans were going to hold
the Senate and that's what happened and
now we're all talking about how
surprising that was and that's the part
that I find kind of interesting when we
hear politicians talk about unity in
their acceptance speeches we know that
you know in a few hours
that will be exchanged with reality this
is that used to happen in politics
people to have big fights and then they
would work together but that second part
seems to have fallen away what did they
know and how did they do it in the past
when they'd fight like cats and dogs and
then and then actually do some business
together what can they learn that they
might apply to well what has happened
John I think is that as the Republicans
moved more to the right Democrats moved
more to the left I mean when I came to
Washington we had Liberal Democrats and
conservative Democrats we had liberal
Republicans and conservative Republicans
and it was the conservative Democrats
and the liberal Republicans who could
always get the web together and figure
out a way to do something now
compromise frankly it's become a dirty
word and you know everybody's talking
about unity I don't see any sign that
there's going to be any unity I think
we're in I hate to be you know sound
like Scrooge here before Christmas but I
don't think I don't think the two sides
are going to come together I think we're
in for a lot of gridlock up to the
president though Bob to set the tone for
that he's already sent a tweet out this
morning basically saying game on to the
Democrats who want to challenge him well
that investigative you know this was
really the first midterm that I can
remember when a president didn't seem to
want to expand his support but motivate
the people who voted for him in in 2016
so I don't see that changing very much
they have the greatest country in the
world but democracy is messy
it found errs knew that when they
established democracy philosophers
talked about it for for centuries but
what we've seen also too is a more
diverse house there is a sliver of
optimism there in terms of more women
more veterans more people of color more
gay Americans bisexual Americans they're
going to be in Congress does that change
how Washington operates well it should
and and I think that's one of the things
that we want to think about I'm trying
to figure out John and I were talking
earlier this morning I don't know what
to make of this I'm still and but it
really doesn't matter what I make of it
I think what if any what lection in
general the election in general I think
what matters is what the two parties and
the party leaders make of it I mean if I
were in the Republican Party right now I
would say we got to find some way to
appeal to these women because they're
the growing force and and you know if if
this is going to be a party just
basically of old white men that's that's
a depleting resource that's not going to
do it they're gonna have to do something
to broaden their appeal if if I were in
the Democratic leadership right now I
would say you know what we need to do is
find something in some way to help
people and and you know they're talking
about health care and all that I think
that's important but I think going into
this saying
our main objective here is to do all
these investigations I just don't think
that's going to be a saleable thing but
you know we're gonna see what happens
and and we'll find a way I mean this is
not the first time in our history that
we've gone through a crisis like this
Jon Meacham has a wonderful book called
the soul of America where he talks about
the crisis crises that we we have
survived I think in some ways he may be
a little bit optimistic about it
but I think we ought to we ought to
think about that you know I ran or ran
across a quote the other day and and I
want to do this just because nobody ever
quotes Martin Van Buren sorry van Buren
like Martin Van Buren said at one point
the government should not be guided by
contemporary excitement but by sober
second thought I think if both parties
could kind of keep that in mind that's
maybe it would be a starting point to
getting back to where we know this
country can be this is a strong country
it's a great country we've got to figure
out a way last thing we ran was a
one-term president thank you